just because moderate Republicans and
centrists for example don't like the
Maga label or everything that Maga
stands for doesn't mean they won't vote
for Trump anyway there is a huge
difference there's a canyon between I
don't like Trump and I'd vote for a
Democrat like Joe Biden those are two
very very different things Trump got 74
million votes in 2020. these were not
just the Fringe and extremists of the
Republican party we have to understand
this on the left yes maga's not
particularly well liked many Republicans
don't like Trump low favorability all of
it is true
but when you get 74 million votes it's
not just the Fringe extremists from your
party